a nativity play performed in Italy's
Sabina Hills near the village of Greta
this is where Saint Francis of Assisi
created the very first nativity play
back in the 13th century I want to
create a new Bethlehem here
Federico Giovanelli hails from Gretchen
every year he stars as Francis of Assisi
in the play this is a very old tradition
that dates back to 1223 when Francis of
Assisi returned from Palestine he hiked
through this region which reminded him a
lot of the Holy Land so he stayed here
and asked his friend to Gretchen
nobleman Giovanni Bonita to stage a
nativity play yes they probably did the
organ is very impressive
Saint Francis's legacy is still
omnipresent in the medieval village of
Gretchen nearby a mighty Franciscan
monastery sits atop a Monti litter on a
cliff ledge many visitors come here to
see the grotto where Francis staged the
first ever nativity play in 12:23 to
bring the story of Christmas closer to
the people
volley proper quadrature in Corcovado he
wanted to portray the birth of Jesus
Christ for everyone to see with their
very own eyes so they can better grasp
and appreciate it so the mostello that
on a sheet of the senior the grotto
features a 14th century fresco depicting
Mary the baby Jesus and a kneeling and
praying Francis
34 years ago new life was breathed into
this nativity play tradition now every
year starting on December 24th the
nativity play is performed in front of
an international audience presumably
gradual a totalmente organ is added our
gently pour the correction nativity play
is organized by enthusiastic locals it's
become a tradition since 1973 they
volunteer they're not paid to do this to
$20 gratuity well maintain $80 wore de
voluntario great show has also opened a
unique nativity museum featuring
exhibits from Italy and other countries
this nativity scene for example comes
from Botswana in Africa
these are all wonderful but I like the
Alaskan exhibit best represent the birth
of Jesus Christ represents the family we
can all relate to this aspect of the
Christian faith it's one of Italy's most
important religious traditions many
market stalls and retro also offers
small nativity scenes some pretty
unconventional options are available
this is shaped like a swan and is made
from a pumpkin it was hollowed out and
worked on for two years
it contains figurines made from cloth
corner usako for the locals the nativity
scene is an important aspect of
Christmas but the highlight each
Christmas remains the actual play of
course it's performed between December
24th and January 6th and gets visitors
from all over the world into the
Christmas spirit